okay we had this one game show i think
it was i don't know if it was british
first it's called golden balls did you
ever watch this oh yeah i didn't watch
that yeah yeah i know i know
yeah golden balls and i can't so what
would happen is
that they would get like five balls each
and
they all had different amounts of money
in them right and then they basically
have to like negotiate i think
ah no no so could you kick off
sorry so no no no um like a football
game no i i've seen i haven't actually
seen it but
i think we're thinking of the right one
where the last round the last round is
it's the most it's the most interesting
one so you have a prize pool
and it's it's i think it's based on like
the prisoner's dilemma or something i'm
probably wrong on that but
so you have two people and you basically
have to
agree if you're going to share the prize
pool
um and or like okay so you have a
steal or share yeah right you can steal
the entire prize pool
or you can share the prize pool and if
you share if if both people pick share
then you share the prize money but if
one person picks steal
they get the entire amount of the prize
oh okay but if both people pick steal
then no one gets nobody gets that price
you saw like the
biggest pieces of [ __ ] on this show like
yeah you'd win the money but like i
really see you're like like expose the
world
it was brutal right because this tv show
[ __ ] loved it because they were like
bro
whatever you got to do to get this money
you ham it up
so these people would do like massive
sob stories to the person next
yeah right and they would believe them
they'd be like man my kids
you know they need this thing real bad
man they're like you know they need this
expensive thing etcetera
and then and then they you know they
would do it and then they reveal like
they stole all the money yeah and
everyone's like okay sure you won 10
grand but yeah and what caught you
what cost at what cost you they go
through their like entire life story to
be like
i uh i'm a devout christian i've given
to charity
i am the most honest person you could
ever meet in your life literally
was just like i'm going to reject
humanity to get this money
i think i've seen the same clip right
was it which one which one was there the
guy who just
[ __ ] hacked like social hacked the
game where he was just like
look mate i'm gonna pick steel yeah and
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's such
a such a like a five head move he
literally goes to the guy look i'm not
even gonna pretend
i'm going to pick steel okay and what
i'm going to do
is i'm going to share half the prize
money with you
once the game's over and the other guys
was like no
you you can't you can't do that you go
you've got you're like no we're going to
pick share we're going to at least agree
to picture he's like no i'm picking
steel and you're going to have to trust
me
that i'm gonna share the prize money
after the after after the show ends and
right like the other guy asked the host
is this allowed is is this actually
allowed and the host goes whatever
happens after the show we can't
guarantee
you know so he's like he gets shanked
that's your issue yeah yeah so he's like
well i'm gonna pick steel as well then
and he's like fine if you pick steel
we're both gonna lose the money but the
only chance you're gonna have to gain
money
is by picking share right such a [ __ ]
five head moves like this that's like
reverse no no
but but at the end he didn't pick steel
he picked cher
so both of them got the prize money in
the end oh [ __ ] wow and i was just like
dude this this this guy this guy is the
main protagonist of the [ __ ] universe
what a five-head move man that is
literally like the martyr
i'll be the bad guy so that everyone can
win like i just
i just watched like irl code kiosk right
in front of me
this is this is what i saw right here i
i saw like i swear i don't know if this
was like a popular clip i remember one
time the guy like literally came into
the show
because there's four contestants at the
start i believe he was literally just
right from the start being like i'm a
steal
i'm gonna steal no matter what like and
then he stole and then he didn't get
anything see the person also stole wow
so it was like the same thing
but like small brain version where he
was he was like
i'm gonna steal to everyone i was like
yeah we know i'm not giving you any of
it
so am i god imagine you you wait for
months right you go through all the
interviews and [ __ ] you get on the show
finally you have a chance of winning
money and some [ __ ] [ __ ]
immediately just said to everyone i'm
going to ruin the show for all of you
i don't give a [ __ ] you'd be like well
[ __ ] what am i supposed to do
that's like the that's like the what's
the [ __ ] the thing uh the the
millionaire hot seat
thing as well did you have those no we
don't have that i don't think okay
because like
i don't know if it was an america we
definitely had it in australia though so
there's like you know there's like who
wants to be a millionaire which is just
like a one-on-one thing
there's this other version of it called
millionaire hot seat which is basically
it's one game of millionaire but then
there's like four other people in
basically like sitting on the benches
waiting for the person to [ __ ] up and if
one person gets the answer wrong
then it goes to the next person from
where they started that's pretty cool
and so i remember i saw this clip which
is like you start off with five people
right and uh they got to i don't know i
was like the 2000 you know not even
halfway up kind of thing
and i guess it was like a really hard
question so
the first guy gets it wrong and he's
like [ __ ] all right whatever see you
later
next person comes along fully confident
being like well they he basically just
got rid of one of the answers for me
i got this and not only does he get it
wrong but then
the next person during 50 50 he also
gets it wrong
so the fourth person comes up is like
so there's only one answer remaining um
i think it's this one
it's like you're correct but like
imagine waiting
sitting on the benches all that time to
just come up and mean like
thank you for giving me this thank you
for the free money thank you for the
free money
jkc